[MUSIC]
Puppy loves
TV It's nice to watch TV with someone It
's nice to be able to laugh and cry together
Puppy
always says Lily sits next to me
Stopped puppy  Hey
m Lily loves the puppy who is watching TV happily So
I thought I want to make the puppy smile from the TV
When Lily says she's going to join the 500 office Puppy quit your job
That's why you've always been there for me. From the
2nd season, Lee's cuteness and acting are outstanding.
It's
okay, it won't show up on TV
That's how Puppy is a dj bar on TV
It depends on the time I saw a good thing I saw it properly The hair on my legs is that  On the 4th Come on
, it's proof that Masao has grown up a little See you soon
Ah,
eh, I can't wear the look I
want forever ed I want to be like this all the
time Happy putter masa Many people in this drama  But look forward to it, white brush
Hey, ah
, if it's something like an adult, I beat you for
a period of tradition
.